wie könnte so etwas aussehen also diese
schrittweise rückkehr zur normalität
wo fängt man da an welche menschen
können vielleicht zuerst wieder
zurückkehren am arbeitsplatz um da mal
so ein bisschen so eine einordnung zu
bekommen ich finde ich habe also zwei
parameter die eine parameter ist was ist
für den einzelnen für die gesellschaft
leichter verzichtbar und worauf können
wir schwerer verzichten
beispiel lebensunterhalt verdienen
arbeiten gehen können wir schwerer
darauf verzichten als auf die party also
als letztes er wieder party anfangen und
die zweite parameter ist wo ist das
infektionsrisiko auch höher und das ist
definitiv beim party feiern höher
alle trinken aus dem gleichen glas
wasser um armen sich man wird
ausgelassen
das haben wir ja gesehen sie ihr spiel
und das ist leicht hat zum beispiel eben
auch beim arbeiten wenn man abstände ein
held wenn man sich eine hygiene regeln
hält die dinge im griff zu behalten also
das ist für mich zum beispiel parameter
wo man im schrittweise beginnen kann
wenn uns bestimmte branchen zeigen sie
können hygieneregeln und abstandsregeln
umsätzen bei sich sowie die supermärkte
ist ja auch geschafft haben mittlerweile
und alle halten sich ja auch dran wenn
du die schlangen zeit heißt dann sähe es
mit abstand wenn wir das schaffen
miteinander dann können die bereiche wo
das geht eben auch wieder anfangen in
den alltag zurückzukehren sehr knifflig
wenn ich das nur sagen darf jetzt glaube
ich bei schule und kindergarten
ich spiele ja wie für viele eltern wo
die kinder jetzt drei vier wochen zu
hause wo das eine sehr große
herausforderung ist um es mal so zu
sagen auch sehr emotional ist wirklich
schön ist natürlich schön aber auch noch
heraus und vor allem wenn man auch
berufstätig ist oder andere aufgaben
noch hat und ich spüre da schon eine
große
eine große hoffnung darauf dass es auch
da nach ostern schrittweise besser wird
und ich glaube dass wir zumindest
entweder für die berufstätigen eltern da
auch auch schrittweise eine lösung
brauchen das schwierige ist kinder die
zum beispiel im bus zur schule fahren so
ein bus ist natürlich eine während
schlager schlechthin
und deswegen ist es ist es echt wichtig
dass wir da und da sind ja auch die
bildungsminister dran dass wir da kluge
konzepte haben wenn man da schrittweise
wieder startet auch in der schule im
kindergarten das infektionsrisiko zu
minimieren sondern gibt es als drittes
das ist ja heute auch bei der bams auf
seite eins wenn wir hier bei bild sind
die frage wie insbesondere diejenigen
die ein größeres risiko haben die
älteren und diejenigen mit bestimmten
vorerkrankungen wie wir die besonders
schützen
was können sie der krise positives
abgewinnen was haben sie für sich
beschlossen wobei sie denken und das
wird gar nicht mal so schlecht weiß
nicht was ich sehe ist ja dass nach
vielen monaten die wir auch hatten
vorher mit mit viel mut und
aggressivität in der öffentlichen
debatte in der politischen debatte viel
streit und kontroverse wir vielmehr das
gemeinsame in der gesellschaft aber auch
in der politik ja wieder finden
auch viel mehr wertschätzung ich meinen
viele pflegekräfte ärzte polizisten und
polizisten die die busse fahren viele
die heute an ostern arbeiten in dieser
zeit das war immer schon so aber wir
nehmen das endlich mal auch anders war
und ich da kann man ja nur dankeschön
sagen dann diejenigen die heute einmal
mehr für uns am feiertag im einsatz sind
und das spüre ich schon dass da ein
anderes bewusstsein entsteht ein anderes
wir gefühl auch kreativität zu wissen
ich kann jetzt in der
senioreneinrichtung im pflegeheim nicht
rein zu besuchen dann wird vor dem
fenster musiziert wird anders
kommuniziert also ich finde das setzt
gerade wahnsinnig viel positives auch
frei und ich wünsche mir dass wir uns
dass er halt noch nach co
hoffentlich lange nicht an uns dass das
wir uns das erhalten als licht das
gleiche gilt ja für die maßnahme sind ja
sehr starke einschränkungen wie wir das
jetzt alle an ostern merken auch bei
diesem guten wetter merken
alle eigentlich etwas anderes machen
würden oder es anders machen würden als
wir es jetzt machen und gleichzeitig
gibt es eine hohe akzeptanz und die gibt
es ja deswegen weil viele eben auch
sagen ich kann nachvollziehen warum wir
das tun wir bemühen uns ja auch aus dem
ministerium aus der regierung heraus
sehr gut immer wieder auch zu sagen wo
wir gerade stehen
warum wir machen was wir machen und
solange es eine hohe akzeptanz gibt und
eine perspektive natürlich auch das
werden wir das jetzt gemeinsam
durchziehen schrittweise auch zurückgeht
in der normalität
dann halten wir das auch zusammen aus
ich glaube wenn es zwei erlebt würde
dann gäbe es auch ganz schnell eine
gegenreaktion